All right, so we saw this Japanese
Youtuber
Takkyuu geinin
Attach a ball
To the end of a string
Let's try it out!
The good thing with this
you don't have to pick up the balls
0-0
Yes!
Who won?
Tough battle
I think you're going for the head shot
Take cover!
And make sure to subscribe
if you haven't done it already
Let's go for the two million!
Good backhand Emil
Thank you!
Well, thank you for the save!
Good roller
Faster faster!
Just could not get it in time anymore
Try not to blink
We should go and scare people like...
HEY!
Okay so this was quite fun
and it worked surprisingly well
Don't forget to subscribe here
And watch our previous episodes there
Until next time!